in Japan Spider-Man received a unique
adaptation that put a fresh spin on the
character and won over many fans while
the suit largely followed the design of
the comic character the web shooter took
on a bizarre and clunky appearance but
what set it apart was its unusual
capabilities which included the ability
to store the Spider-Man suit and summon
a massive spider Mech known as the
marveler back in 1977 CBS aired The
Amazing Spider-Man a made-for-tv movie
that served as the pilot for a
short-lived TV series starring Nicholas
haymond as the Iconic web Slinger in the
pilot there's a brief sequence that
shows Peter Parker creating his web
shooters however these web shooters
didn't quite resemble the sleek and
sophisticated devices we know today in
the Marvel zombie storyline Spider-Man
gained a unique ability that sets him
apart from his regular counterparts the
ability to use his veins and arteries as
a substitute for his webbing this
allowed him to swing from building to
building even though he was infected by
the zombie virus one of the best and
most unique web shooter designs came
from Earth 8351 Spider-Man became a
highly trained assassin the web shooters
now fired bullets instead of webbing
making them one of the deadliest
versions we've seen